- [Voiceover] Let's do some examples
figuring out the magnitude of a vector
if we're just given some
information about it.
So, one of the simplest cases would be
well, if they just told
us the actual components
of the vector.
So if they said vector a is equal to,
let's say five comma negative three,
this means that its
x-component is positive five,
its y-component is negative three.
Well, if we have this,
then the magnitude of a,
the magnitude of a is just going to be,
and this really just comes
from the distance formula
which just comes from
the Pythagorean theorem,
the magnitude of a is just going to be
the square root
of the x-component squared.
So let me do that in a different color.
So the square root of
the x-component squared,
so five squared,
plus the y-component squared,
so plus negative three squared.
And this is going to be equal to
the square root of 25,
25 plus nine,
plus nine,
which is equal to the square root of 34,
which is equal to the square root of 34.
And if you want to think
about this visually,
this is very easy to do
just looking at the actual components.
But if you want to make sense of this,
why this is essentially just
the Pythagorean theorem,
we could draw out a quick
coordinate axis right over here.
So that's our y-axis.
This is our, let's see,
I have a y-component of negative three.
So let's see.
That is our, actually let me
draw it a little bit different.
Let me draw it like this.
That is our x-axis.
And we see its x-component
is positive five,
so one, two, three, four, five.
That's five there.
And its y-component is negative three.
So one, two, three.
And so this is negative three.
And so we can draw this
vector with its initial point.
Remember, we can always
shift around a vector
as long as we don't change its
magnitude and to direction.
We can start it at the origin,
and make it go five in the x-direction
and negative three in the y-direction,
and so its terminal point
will be right over there
at the point five comma negative three.
And so the vector, the vector,
will look like this.
And if we want to figure
out the magnitude,
that's just the length of this line.
And what we can do is just
set up a right triangle
where our change, our change in y
is this negative three right over here.
That is our change in y.
And our change in x is this positive five,
is that positive five.
And so this is a right triangle.
Five squared plus,
you could just view the absolute value
of this side as three,
so five squared plus three squared
is going to be the hypotenuse squared.
Comes straight out of
the Pythagorean theorem.